- Comme des milliers
de Montréalais, Claude Hamel
doit filtrer son eau pour
qu'elle s contaminée.
CLAUDE HAMEL,
résident du Plateau-Mont-Royal
- Il y a du plomb dans l'eau,
c'est un vieux quartier
avec des infrastructuresqui ont,
on est bien contents
que ça se fasse.
- Montréal sait qu'il y a
du plomb dans son eau depuis
plus de 15 ans. En 2019,
la Ville s'était engagée
à accélérer les remplacements.
Selon les chiffres obtenus
par Radio-Canada, il restera,
à la fin de l'année, près de
50 000 entrées d'eau à changer.
Depuis 2018, 4000 changement
ont été effectués en moyenne
par année.
L'échéancier initial fixé à
2030 a depoussé à 2032.
Mais au rythme actuel, ce serait
plutôt 2034.
- C'est vraiment surprenant,
parce que c'est un enjeu
de santé.
- L'opposition réclame d'abord
plus de prévisibilité
pour les citoyens.
ALAN DeSOUSA, opposition
officielle, Ville de Montréal
- La Ville va leur annoncer :
"Ah oui, on fait ça dans deux
semaines". Tout le monde...
les gens ne peuvent pas juste
tirer l'argent d'un chapeau.
La plupart de nous a besoin
de mettre un peu d'argent
de côté pour être capable
de bien planifier.
- Parce que lorsque la Ville
fait les travaux sur sa section
publique, si la section priv
est aussi en plomb, elle
la remplace en même temps
et facture le propriétaire.
Les risques liés au plomb
sont minimes pour é
de la population, selon
la santé publique de Montréal.
Mais certaines personnes sont
plus à risque, même à faible
concentr
Dr DAVID KAISER, Direction
régionale de santé publique, Mtl
- On parle de jeunes enfants,
de femmes enceintes à cause
des effets possibles
sur les jeunes enfants.
On peut avoir des impacts
au niveau du développement
langagier, cognitif,
alors vraiment les bases
du développement de l'enfant.
- Malgré la cadence
de remplacement insuffisante
jusqu'à maintenant, la Ville
pense pouvoir accélérer
les travaux.
PHILIPPE SABOURIN,
Ville de Montréal
- On est absolument confiants
de terminer en 2032. Pourquoi?
Parce que cette année seulement,
on a remplacé 4000 entrées de
d'eau. Alors, l'objectif
pour les 10 prochaines années,
c'est d'en faire 600 de plus.
Alors, c'est réaliste,
on va atteindre l'objectif 2032.
- Clauderra
se débarasser de son pichet
dans les prochaines semaines.
D'autres vont vivre avec encore
au moins une décennie.
hieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Mon